are you doing here
Seamus seem a lawyer listen you can't
you can't keep coming here we were
wondering about this sandstone in the
front yard and if you'd be willing to
sell it to us you don't have to sell you
don't want to do you know what this you
have to be up them never done this
before
quite know where to start are you
registered to the question ROG the wife
works for you that's funny
no he's the boss section
[Music]
I'm going to tell you the same stuff
I've been telling you I just I want you
to hear it from somebody else
when she was in I saw a girl from my
family supposed to get
feeling where to helping me at all and
because I myself know an interesting
[Music]
can I make an effort to Mongkut because
neither of us to be very well as our I
don't mean to keep you from getting work
or anything as no but in sport Drive
know that we'll see you again I really
can't help it what I can be the bad guy
would be so lovely to think that if I
were a man I could explain a lot people
would listen and say okay would be so
restful
[Music]
you